But at least in something
like hosting the today show,
you are just talking once you put these
sort of diversity standards or something
like mathematics. Oh yeah. That's, that's
when things get super squirrely. Yeah.
They're trying to do that a little bit.
I mean,
you retweeted that thing I wrote about
mathematics and they wanted people to
sign an equity, which is another
word that they've cooperated.
They wanted folks to sign an equity
statement and a diversity statement.
And the thing is, explain that. Explain
what they're trying to, that you, you,
you have a commitment to diversity.
Yeah.
You have a commitment to diversity
and you have a commitment to equity.
And so equity does not mean
treating people equally.
It's not like you have a
commitment to equality,
which is what we should all have a
short material quality. Uh, it's,
equity is defined differently.
It's to make up for past
injustices are to make up for,
um, some deficiency that has occurred
somewhere along the line. So,
yeah,
affirmative action is an equity movement.
It's to treat people differently in
order to level the playing field. Yeah.
So it's not treating people,
it's not treating people equally.
And that's the key thing. It
sounds like it is, but it's not.
It's a word that Dave smuggled in
straight out of the literature. Again,
it's again on all the stuff
comes back to the literature.
So if you look at the word equity in the
dictionary, you'd get one definition.
But if you look at the word equity as
they're applying it and sociological
definitions,
it's a very specific thing that means
something slightly different from what
people assume. So here's the
question you should ask somebody.
Anytime you hear someone used the word
equity, just ask all I'm, I'm curious,
why didn't you use the word equality?
Can, can you, can you think of it?
Would the sentence be the same
with the meaning be the same? Well,
the meaning is not the same. That's
why they used equity and not equality.
Equity is a finance word. That's why
it's weird. It is also fun. Yeah.
So they don't make up new words,
right? They go up. Yeah. They call up,
they change and then they smuggle
diversity inclusion, right.
These academic papers and
they come up with these ideas.
They start with their conclusion,
they push it through,
it gets published and that's just like,
it's like the academic equivalent of money
laundering does money laundering work.
Yes. You take some money, you got
ill gotten money, you put it through,
you know this shell company or this thing
or the other thing and it comes back
to you and now it's had illegal
trail that makes it legit. Right.
Well here you take some prejudice,
you write it down as an academic paper,
you published a thing,
it gets the academic standard stamp on it.
It's the gold standard of
knowledge now and now this is,
this prejudice you started with now looks
like legitimate knowledge that can go
straight in the classroom.
It can go straight to exactly.
Activists or policymakers.
It's a real problem. Yeah,
and when then really funny though that
you're just saying it's like can't get
DEMEC Moneyline it is. Yeah. That's bread.
That's just for our Weinstein said that
Bret Weinstein said that and that's what
it is.
It comes out the other side is knowledge.
So then they think they have knowledge,
right.